merci bravo et voilà donc maintenant
j'espère serre est prêt à répondre à mes
appels alors est donc sacré quatrième
dauphine 1987 nous vous écoutons
autrement dit celle qui occupe la 5e
place alors nous avons les résultats
exacts cas 4e 4e dauphine quatrième
dauphine c'est la noce et le lille
métropole lille métropole caroline lille
métrople quatrième dauphine qui va
recevoir son écharpe des mains de miss
france 86 et qui va les prendre sa place
sur le podium au pied des marches ou via
monte dans quelques instants à miss
france 87 alors europe numéro un voulez
vous nous indiquez très vite alors que
les impositions encore bis métropole
quand même qu elle est la dauphine
numéro 3 la troisième dauphine la
troisième dauphine troisième dauphine
c'est ces tricycles attendait parce que
là on a revu cette femme petite erreur
oui là la troisième dauphine c'est la
camargue
stéphane brachet
kamaishi vous ne vous trompez pas c'est
très grave
certains certains ont même apporté le
coach espère que vous êtes entourés de
nombreux comptable expert experts merci
experts voient la deuxième dauphine deux
soeurs attendez attendez on applaudit
maintenant qu'elle a ceint l'écharpé de
3e dauphine miss camargue
voici la deuxième dauphine qui est
bientôt fait une troisième dauphine
pardon de cécile deuxième dauphine
complètement troublé parce que je sais
pas si tu manques est ce que vous seriez
ces traités comme nous à côté de ces 8es
oui vous sauriez vous deuxième dauphine
donc c'est là la réunion avec joël ramia
millions
est ce que vous êtes sûr de votre
classement je vous avais dit tout à
l'heure que les parisiens étaient plus
se tourner vers la chaleur
attendez attendez ou est-ce que j'en
suis 2e dauphine deuxième dauphine
qu'est-ce qui se passe désir qu'est-ce
qui est la nôtre vis elle se fâche tabac
une miss proteste dit que pourtant pour
la première fois ci le public qui vote
et personne d'autre miss réunion par
conséquent deuxième dauphine tel est le
verdict de nos amis qui ont voté par
milliers en europe nommé roi ça ne l'est
pas semble-t-il la faveur du public mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez vous êtes sûr
de votre résultat mon cher céleste
non non ce n'était pas des roms attendez
je pense que si vous perdez les erreurs
c'est très très grave
peter webber s'en va pour m attendez on
refait on refait le squelette est bon
e céleste attendez attendez attendez 30
ans bredouille et quelque chose qui est
exact 4 seles
oui je suis là je suis là attendait
effectivement on a peut-être quelques
années quand même des gens qui sont
capables de l'europe
oui de faire décanter xalatan dès le
numéro 5 et est attribué à qui amuse
réunion et coûteux non diarra est en
train devait très bien il n'y a aucun
problème là
ou est ce que nous en sommes attendez
nous avons donc donné la 4e' de la
cinquième et quatrième dauphines la
troisième dauphine la deuxième
enfin vous n'êtes pas entouré de gens
capables de faire des comptes sérieux
monsieur céleste ça me paraît quand même
très grave
la deuxième dauphine on est en mesure de
l'affirmer complètement d'une façon très
sincère c'est joël ramia de la réunion
2e dauphine c'est à dire qui est classée
troisième dans votre classement
attendait effectivement c'est là où je
butais la non en fait il ya une grosse
erreur là
3 oh là là ça y est nous y sommes
quel pétrin vous êtes en train de nous
mettre mon chien écoutez moi là que l'on
pensait qu'on pouvait faire confiance en
europe
alors on peut faire confiance à
quelqu'un vraiment je trouve
complètement perdus alors que finalement
on vous a ramené un vote à cinq
candidates pourquoi vous vous trompiez
c'est quand même assez grave la deuxième
dauphine et la camargue avec stéphane
brachet deuxième dauphine nous y sommes
ça y est
et écoutez je vais vous et des crs parce
qu'il ya quelque chose qui va pas oui ok
et cassis 5e 5e c'est lille métropole
qui est classé quatrième
c'est la grande motte avec grande motte
qui est classée troisième c'est la
camargue quitte donc deuxième dauphine
camargue et non par réunion c'est bien
cela c'est ça tout à fait pas bravo
merci pour nous avoir fait des émotions
et j'ai cru que nous allions avoir une
émeute ici alors 2 3e classe i troisième
est étendu à une deuxième dauphine la
grande la camargue classique maintenant
reveillere dauphine c'est à dire classé
12e eh bien ce n'est qu'une juste
récompense pour la réunion puisque les
premières dauphines la réunion la
réunion 1ère dauphine voulez-vous belle
demoiselle
je m'excuse de mettre un petit peu
énervé mais ça n'allait pas du tout du
côté de roc
les bobos place s'il vous plaît au pied
du podium rené mesdemoiselles
mon amie sophie
et
il y en a une qui est parti ne sais pas
pourquoi dieu
et donc par conséquent élue miss france
1987 europe avec 42% points 2 des voix
nathalie marquay sur l'alsace
miss alsace miss france
et ben voilà d'élections houleuse
l'élection le ce médoc secours que ce
n'est pas très gentil
ici nos amis du fiqh parce que je trouve
que miss alsace et ravissante et je
voudrais bien quand même que même si
miss réunion semblait ici dans cette
salle de 3 400 personnes remporté les
suffrages n'avons pas aller contre des
milliers de voix de auditeurs et des
téléspectateurs qui ont téléphoné europe
et qui ont sacré nice alsace
miss france 85
voilà nous allons apporter cette pièce
montée que nous quand edgar traiteur à
paris et à monsieur pierre-yves vous
avez vous la montée lanoye côtés de miss
france car maintenant on peut me laisser
les photographes intervenir maintenant
vous pouvez arriver messieurs les
photographes pour prendre miss france
comme il ya une dauphine qui est parti
je propose de la remplacer par miss
lorraine avec miss lorraine
mr quatrième dauphine si vous voulez me
revenir puisque l'autre a considéré
qu'elle n'était pas digne d'être
dauphiné qu'elle voulait peut-être être
miss france voilà alors je voudrais
simplement maintenant vous remercier
tous et toutes
j'espère céleste que vous étiez de ce
résultat final quand même
so lu ment sur glee c'est un peu dommage
que nous soyons comme on dit amélie les
crayons avec les premières deuxièmes
extra et dope insee toujours pardon je
vous entends très mal si on n'a pas
l'habitude d'élire une miss france ici
oui m'enfin vous est peut-être quand
même l'habitude de lire des chiffres
parce que c'est pas le premier sondage
que vous faites et je trouve un petit
peu désolant ce qui s'est passé m'enfin
tant pis ce qui prouve que tout vous
n'êtes toujours pas tous parfaits quand
on commence une première fois c'était
pourtant simple on avait ramené alors je
voudrais que vous applaudissent y ait
une dernière fois ici au studio 15 des
buttes chaumont à paris et partout
ailleurs et dispense élan nos fils et
ses dauphines c'est derrière miss france
miss alsace miss réunion et sa première
dauphine miss grande mode sa deuxième
miss camargue sa troisième et la
quatrième n'est pas alors c'est sur ces
images que je vous ne les rendez vous à
mais la pièce ponte monsieur thierry
vous pouvez vous lamentez alors
mademoiselle mademoiselle miss alsace
voulez-vous venir près de la pièce
montée découpez la première part de
gâteau c'est sur ces images que nous
allons nous séparer
pour ma part je vous donne rendez vous
le 21 février le 21 janvier pardon à
avoriaz où nous retrouverons
traditionnellement notre émission c'est
aujourd'hui demain avec son côté
fantastique puisque ce sera dans le code
du festival du film du même nom
ce sera je peux vous le promettre une
soirée fantastique
celle de ce soir a eu quelques
soubresauts
nous avons eu quelques ennuis au niveau
du vote
cela dit je pense que c'est tout à fait
définitif n'est ce pas mon cher céleste
oui pas problème le problème gaza ce qui
coûte aux amas tranche de gâteau 1987
qui est sacrée miss france c'est bien
miss réunion qui est sa première
dauphine
on peut dire sa vie sereine et c'est
bien sûr que nous avons récoltées de
quoi ouvrir les portes de sa maison à
l'abbé pierre et croyez moi finalement
c'était bien ça le plus important
bonsoir à tous et bonne année encore au
21 janvier pour notre prochaine émission
au revoir à tous